Годі кашляти вже! Все, лебідь, який помирає.
Син Ольги Журавської з Вітебська захворів у середині березня.
У мене син спілкувався з хлопцями, які їздили на екскурсію до Італії.
Приїхали, їхній клас єдиний у школі закрили на карантин.
Інших, хто з ними спілкувався, не перевіряли.
Через тиждень Ольга теж захворІла.
У мене спочатку була не дуже висока температура - 37,8, потім 37,6.
А потім різко стало 38,5. У мене "горіли" легені,
у мене сльозилися очі. У мене кашель був сухий, він не проходив годинами.
За цю відеозйомку в лікарні Ольгу звинуватили
в хуліганстві, завели кримінальну справу та оштрафували.
Вона розповідає, що лікарні в місті переповнені.
Про це говорить і Ольга Карач, опозиціонерка з Вітебська.
Що можна точно сказати, то це те, що
всі лікарні Вітебська забиті хворими на цю дивну двосторонню пневмонію.
І люди перебувають у дуже важкому стані.
Тобто в нас у Вітебську на даний момент
є дуже велика інфекційна лікарня, вона саме навпроти мого будинку,
і там два корпуси по чотири поверхи, і там поруч туберкульозний диспансер,
тобто там досить велика лікарня, щоб, умовно кажучи,
вмістити і сезонну пневмонію, і ГРВІ, і бронхіт.
Так от, ця лікарня забита. Вже забита і міська лікарня, і залізнична, і лікарня швидкої допомоги.
Лікарка з вітебської швидкої допомоги Наталя Ларіонова
на своїй сторінці у соцмережах написала, що ситуація з коронавірусом у місті
стає неконтрольованою.
Після того, як вона це запостила, її викликали в прокуратуру.
Білоруський президент Олександр Лукашенко неодноразово давав зрозуміти,
що не вважає ситуацію з коронавірусом серйозною.
- Краще померти стоячи, ніж жити на колінах.
- А є щось, що може Вас зупинити від виходу на лід?
- Мене? А навіщо? Можна, але навіщо, я не розумію.
Тут немає жодних вірусів. От ти ж не помітила, що вони літають? І я теж не бачу.
Через три тижні після цього матчу Лукашенко повідомить, що
у Вітебську коронавірусом заразилися понад 10 лікарів, які контактували з пацієнтами.
Але спише все на те, що лікарі нібито знехтували заходами безпеки.
Обмовиться він і про те, що вперше коронавірус у Вітебськ привезлИ на взуттєву фабрику.
Про це в місті відомо вже давно.
З 13-14 березня, приміром, пішли на негласний карантин всі взуттєві фабрики Вітебська.
Це пов'язано з тим, що взуттєва делегація з Вітебська наприкінці лютого
була в Італії для обміну досвідом. Вона повернулася першого або другого березня.
Кілька десятків людей приїхали з Італії і ходили містом.
Виходить, що вони зіграли роль суперрозповсюджувачів.
Тому Вітебськ перший спалахнув.
Позиція білоруського президента зв'язує руки чиновникам
у міністерстві охорони здоров'я, вважає Ольга Карач.
У них вже достатньо документів гуляє про те, що вони намагаються
ухвалити досить серйозні заходи. Але вони не можуть офіційно оголосити карантин,
тому що Олександр Лукашенко сказав, що коронавірусу не існує,
його не видно, це все психоз. Вони не можуть заперечувати того, хто вище,
тому намагаються все робити таємно.
Про те, що МОЗ Білорусі, може намагатися приховати інформацію про ситуацію в країні,
говорять і незалежні журналісти.
Міністерство охорони здоров'я періодично видає пресрелізи, але не щодня.
У них, повторюся, набір цифр, з якими треба дуже серйозно працювати,
щоб отримати якусь більш-менш чітку інформацію.
До інформації від офіційної влади довіри стає дедалі менше, тому що складається враження,
що ця інформація відповідним чином препарується і не завжди є достовірною.
На відміну від міністерства охорони здоров’я Білорусі,
несподівано швидко відреагувало інше відомство, розповідає Ольга Карач.
Єдина структура, яка дуже оперативно спрацювала, -
це департамент виконання покарань.
Вони одразу запровадили карантин вусіх тюрмах, миттєво.
Вони заборонили усі побачення і так далі.
Натомість дозволили - як виняток - передачу.
Передачу, яку в народі вже прозвали "коронавірусною".
Це десять кілограмів, дозволено передавати тільки цибулю і цитрусові.
Поки в Білорусі триває чемпіонат з футболу - єдиний діючий у Європі.
Через це він опинився під пильною увагою фанатів із цілого світу
й приніс білоруській футбольній лізі нові контракти на трансляцію.
Нові ТВ-контракти! Білорусь перетворює коронавірусну нерозсудливість на золото,
пише німецьке видання "Більд".
Оскільки у футбол більше ніде не грають, фанати з цІлого світу
дивляться матчі з Білорусі. Щоб побачити лайв-трансляцію бодай якогось матчу.
Але запланований на 5 квітня футбольний матч у Вітебську перенесли.
Першою підтвердженої смертю від коронавірусу в місті
стала смерть 75-річного актора Вітебського театру.
Про нього Лукашенко заявив, що це бідолаха,
який ходив на роботу і помер від коронавірусу,
але у свідоцтві про смерть у нього написано "невизначена пневмонія",
а не коронавірус. Тобто виходить, що такого роду нестиковки
теж породжують дуже велику недовіру до влади.
За останніми даними білоруського МОЗ,
загалом у країні вже зафіксовано понад 700 випадків інфікування коронавірусом.
Щонайменше 13 осіб померли, 53 одужали.